so
have you taken a cognitive no i haven't
taken the test
why the hell would i take a test come on
man
that's like saying you before you got in
this program if you take a test where
you're taking cocaine or not what do you
think huh
are you what do you say to president
trump
who brags about his test and makes your
mental state
an issue for voters well
if he can't figure out the difference
between an elephant and a lion
i don't know what the hell he's talking
about did you watch that look come on
man i i know you're trying to goad me
but i mean i'm so forward-looking to
have
an opportunity to sit with the president
or stand with the president and debates
they're going to be plenty of time and
by the way as i joke with them you know
i i shouldn't say i'm going to say
something i don't i i probably shouldn't
say
anyway i am uh i am very
willing to let the american public judge
my physical mental filter
my physical
what's up ladies and gentlemen my
defensive mental
my mental my pencil
ladies and gentlemen that was the
democratic the 2020 democratic nominee
joseph biden
uh calling that black dude a junkie
um he did that's what he did didn't he
yeah he did
well actually are you a junkie
joseph vladimir biden is this didn't
know his middle name
okay okay all right he said so forward
i'm so forward looking that's not even
you mean looking forward
yeah looking forward yeah and we just
found out that he's not even gonna show
up to his convention
nope no he canceled out yeah did you see
him in the video though he grabbed his
ear like this
i don't think he was itching it i think
that meant come on guys call me out of
here because i'm starting to get a
little dementi
how he smiled too he smiled and that
took me back to
his debate against uh paul ryan where he
just smiled
up and i was like oh that's that's his
that's his little game that he's playing
okay remember i told you before
when he gets lost he'll go look i don't
want to say what i'm going to say
so i won't because he doesn't know what
he's going to say or
i kind of feel like he was going to say
something bad yeah yeah he doesn't know
or you know more than he does about it
or you know that's when joe biden hits
one of those
listen here folks every time he goes
serious
hey listen there folks this is not a
game so
you know whatever um
let's start the show off with um beirut
we kind of talked about it yesterday
during the show oh first off what's up
facebook
rt our international audience hey how is
everybody doing
and um our international audience and
thank you
for from the many countries that are
watching us right now
and one of the reasons why i'm happy
that uh
uh that rt is uh uh
allowing us to uh uh
to broadcast is because we get to see
well a lot of people across the country
get to see us
and get hear opinions from regular
americans
rather than the media that continues
to i mean yesterday they spent what a
coup a few hours talking about how
president trump was
um uh pronounced yosemite
i mean beirut was when what was
happening with beirut was crazy
right yeah no i
thank you rt and um i i will say rt
doesn't give us talking points they
don't play
no we just do our thing yeah they they
allow us to do our thing and
um i appreciate that and
that's a note to all the other american
networks that turned us down
uh i wouldn't say any names like
siriusxm
did we get turned i thought we were
still under review
serious they won't even respond to me
sounds good it's because you speak the
truth
serious patrick look and then they have
people
you know breitbart's one of them uh
you know newsmax another one
you know i i mean i i i don't understand
i don't understand but then you know
whatever whatever we we're here and
we're
uh broadcasting and we are
we're having a good time but we're also
trying to get some news out to you
facebook youtube periscope
clout hub parlor and uh
any other networks that will broadcast
oh i'm fired up by the new app oh yeah
oh man
i'm fired up about that i'm waiting for
my iphone man i'm getting warmed up
iphone app isn't coming the new iphone
i mean the new waiting to pre iphone app
should be
here in the next couple of days it's um
things have been cleared as of yesterday
so we're just waiting but it
is available on android you can download
it on android and ladies and gentlemen
it is a doozy of an app okay it's a
doozy ever app but you know we'll talk
about it
in a little bit but um you're gonna love
it so
uh beirut
yeah root you know so many people were
saying it was a fireworks
facility you know well the people
in beirut like like the uh
the health minister who has ties to uh
hezbollah was saying that he was the one
that was trying to spread
the misinformation that's the first
place i heard it so yeah you're correct
right so now we've got israel on the
ground i trust israel i do
folks i know you probably hate me for
saying this some of you israel taking
over the world and
the zionists and all this other bs but i
trust israel
they're doing what they're doing and the
intel coming out
said that it was a partnership between
hezbollah and iran as a weapons facility
and for all intents purposes all the
video footage
uh that lends credence i i'm going to
agree with that
and now they're saying that ammonium
nitrate
had exploded it was 2700
tons 2 700 tons of ammonium nitrate
and if you guys remember back the
oklahoma city bombing
does anybody remember how many tons
timothy mcveigh used
two just a little over two it was all
three
three times for oklahoma city this was 2
700 tons yeah and you could tell by the
video
they just said that lebanon is putting
port officials under house arrest now
because they're saying they knew the
port officials knew that
those chemicals were stored underground
and they have done nothing with them for
six
years right so now they're under house
arrest
for negligence the the um
we have a video i
i went out i went out and saw this um i
went out and got
this video of it but the the um beirut
bless
the video was something that it looked
i'm not trying to compare it to 911 but
i mean it just
looked that it does when i saw
yeah when i saw the results of it i was
like wow does this remind me of 911
yeah so you know with the
with the people a lot of people hurt uh
i mean the carnage the buildings that
were
that that i mean just we saw we all saw
the blast you know
right and the ground the way that the
ground
shook right that's the thing that got me
i was like there's no way that thing is
a fireworks
facility type of thing yeah right now
that that percussion blast that some of
the people that
were probably about like filming maybe
three quarters of a mile to a mile away
and the seconds one two just counting
the seconds down and all of a sudden
the uh the sound catches up to him yeah
just
just mind-blowing uh windows shattered
people knocked to the ground miles away
somebody said
oh somebody was saying nuclear blast i
know we kind of mentioned that yesterday
yeah i mean we were just going off
for but yeah normally nuclear blast has
a big flash but
i will tell you if you remember after 9
11 the firefighters that died 10 years
later
because of all the chemicals that they
breathed in they're saying that air
is just full of chemicals right now so
now i feel bad for all those first
responders
like them right there that are breathing
this in uh we got jolly on
uh periscope said that it registered a
four point three on the richter scale
yes it did it was dead holy i agree
but um ladies and gentlemen
uh next the next
um the next video i'm going to show you
be prepared for it yeah be very prepared
um
no i was just going to say if you
haven't seen this video yet it's
i mean it's just unbelievable yeah yeah
this is
this is um real time what happened
it was doing an interview as a matter of
fact uh
brace yourselves and um i'm
and i hope hopefully everything is fine
hopefully everything's fine
this is from the bbc
hello
oh
this is considered an accident this is
considered an
axe that looks like something out of a
movie how can we have an
accident of this magnitude the
negligence it's just beyond it's
mind-blowing the negligence
yeah i mean when i saw it i really felt
for her
because she didn't and and if you
heard we saw the video yesterday
and we heard the boom and then we saw
that
the the wave of the air come afterwards
and that's exactly what happened in that
video yeah i heard the boom
and she got up and then the wave of air
smashed that building
i'm just glad that she was able to stand
up i i mean
that's ah you know that her eardrums had
to be
oh man probably ringing all day yeah
yeah
and look um peasant just says i thought
it was nuclear
nuclear hit my head first but i was like
it was more like atomic to me
than yeah nuclear right you know and
somebody said it was uh uh it was like a
moab
uh bomb too so that's the biggest one we
have
yeah yeah that's the one that trump sent
in to uh
like bunker busters you know to get get
people to hit the ground
and get them underground yeah yeah so
i mean i i really um the world right now
is uh uh um offering help
over there to the many that are dead how
many are dead again
under a hundred but thousands thousands
and they said three hundred thousand are
homeless now because of it
right right the homelessness is that
yeah the homelessness is unbelievable uh
the deaths they're saying are absolutely
going to go up they just can't find
anybody right and they don't have power
they don't have electricity at night so
it's hard for them to search the rubble
at night
they pretty much have to stop searching
because they don't have electricity
there at night
they've rolling power outages yeah
israel
israel has offered assistance as well
which
yeah no i mean we're praying we're
praying for all of them
um you know we're praying to
we're praying to hopefully um
they recover yeah hopefully they recover
but yeah that that was the beirut side
on yesterday and
um many of you were shocked and
many of you are still taking beirut
lebanon somebody said
where did this happen beirut lebanon
yeah where did this happen
oh my goodness you under a rock
some people just don't watch the news so
they get it here
absolutely and for those of you who are
fired up and upset that everybody's in
shock and all
of the explosion that's human nature
to watch that and be in shock and awe of
something of that magnitude
nobody's praising it nobody's happy that
it happened
right no it's just a shock and all but i
saw on social media
people just outright i'm outraged that
you guys are watching
and you're sharing the explosion and
this and that no it's
this is real life yeah you have to show
what's out there
because knowledge is power right we can
stop it somewhere else from happening
then
yeah so for those of you who just jumped
on the uh
the scope or the show wherever you're at
twitter facebook's parlors
youtubes uh we just showed the video and
we're talking about
the explosion in beirut yesterday the
ammonium nitrate that was used in the
oklahoma city bombing
was three and almost three and a half
tons in oklahoma city bombing
this they're reporting 2700
2 700 tons
of ammonium nitrate
just even thinking about just saying
that and thinking about that gives me
chills
and the fact that it was just sitting
there uh for six years
just whatever whatever they're saying
that hezbollah and iran
are tied to this well
um while while we're talking
and showing that video facebook just
blocked
the entire show so
yeah facebook just blocked the entire
show uh and the bbc
i guess put in the claim on that video
which was
i already said it well actually it um
actually it blocked it on rt i can still
see
it showing it's got seven
it says 17 minutes ago
yeah yeah it it's still it's still live
for us
but um it doesn't look like it's out
so um all right facebook even though i
did say this was from bbc and
uh why would it be blocked because the
sound it made
i don't know yeah they have what they
have algorithms and they
they you know listen for certain things
certain things are said and their
computers pick it up
and then there's automatic blocks from
computers or bots or whatnot
this is obviously fair use this falls
under the fair use act
we are talking about the clip we're
showing the clip
and we're talking about uh basically is
there a way you're like allowed to veto
that or argue it or anything
they are working it out right now
wow i just got a message from them that
um
they are working it out uh for those
that are on my facebook page just
share it okay uh share it at
share this as much as you can let's see
yeah that way the other people can maybe
jump on if you could share yeah
share it okay um be rude okay so with
that said
um
that kind of that kind of knocked me for
a loop too
yeah uh yesterday
sorry about that
how about sally yates
okay um president trump
ladies and gentlemen he does not want
americans evicted
because of the pandemic um
and i hope that many of you
are pushing that message out there
because there are
a lot of individuals right now that uh
are
going through this where president trump
said on monday that he's looking
at unilaterally taking steps to stop
tenant
evictions and lower payroll taxes adding
that
such moves might be necessary if a new
corona virus bill can't be brokered
with congressional democrats a lot of
people are going to be evicted
but i'm going to stop it because i do it
i i'll do it myself if i have to that's
what he told reporters have mentioned
that his staff is
sit looking very seriously at various
executive order powers that he has
um why is
this an issue i'm gonna be cynical
like i always am these these reporters
these news outlets
uh social media everything has made me
probably the most cynical person i have
ever met
and i can't help it but damn it is about
the election
crush the people divide the people put
them on the streets
cause and inflict as much pain as
possible to the american public
get them outraged get them angered
and then get rid of trump
yeah okay it's kind of the obama effect
get everybody as low as you can
make sure they have no money make sure
they have no jobs so that way they're
co-dependent on the government
and then rack up trillions of dollars in
government spending
and then say that he did a wonderful job
and that's exactly what the democrat
party is about
yes a grocery stores you know i call
them out as you see them
krogers ralphs all y'all home depot
lowe's none y'all closed my hairdresser
give a shout out
penny very nice the greatest thing i've
ever had on the west side of cincinnati
uh my girl penny she had a closure
the beauty salon if it wasn't for her
husband
and the fact that she's been doing this
for 20 30 years and
you know she had nest eggs saved up it
just she couldn't have survived it
so shut everybody down except the
grocery store
and that's just it they just keep
putting us in the washing machine
and and they just or and they just keep
on hitting us and hitting us with more
issues
and like you said home dec depot can be
open but yet my friend who's a hair
stylist can't be
i don't understand there's more people
in home depot that could spread it than
her little hair salon right and no no no
fault to home depot
at all no no and during the whole
pandemic
home depot sales almost doubled almost
doubled
uh their sales right now are beyond
anything that they had last year
currently now uh but yet restaurants
you know waitresses waiters people that
are just getting by
your lives have been crushed this is
what kind of makes me sick about the
whole thing
you during pandemic you see walmart
home depot all these big box stores
saying we're here for you we're going to
stay open for you
we're we love you and i'm thinking
myself
boy they're loving this because all the
mom and pop shops are shut
down yep and they're getting all the
money they're getting
all the consumers and all these pop
shops that we're staying open and we're
getting
those crowds in and getting people to
spend money with them
now have to go to walmart now i have to
go to home depot they can't go to the
mom and pop shops do you really think
walmart and big box stores care about it
right planned parenthood get back that
80 million dollars
corona no
the hypocrisy knows no bounds folks i'm
telling you
now we're getting reports out of sweden
switzerland
the netherlands holland somewhere out
there that they're scientists that have
studied
the mask are saying no the masks do not
prove any kind of out whatsoever
we're reopening switzer sweden
completely open
kids are all going back to school this
is enough is enough this has to stop
maybe at one point in time those masters
okay all right
enough is enough well i will say they
did a study and showed that the
countries that locked down the hardest
have been hit the hardest
with the chronovirus you have these
mastercard there's there's reports now
in articles i'm reading i'm seeing
people are getting infections lung
infections from breathing these
these the same stuff in the mass they're
not changing it out
legionnaires disease i think that's one
of what
it's called okay if they're breathing
their own bacteria in
legionnaires disease is kind of it kind
of gives you the exact same
um symptoms as chronovirus so a lot of
these people
maybe have legionnaires disease you just
i don't know
it's scary to think what they're doing
to us
the head nurse that i spoke to a couple
weeks ago
that she works down at the va here in
cincinnati downtown at the va in
cincinnati
and one of the patients came in he was
drunk
and fell down the night before cracked
some ribs
and he came in because he had cracked
ribs and they were saying he's got heavy
breathing he's
heart of breathing he's covered he's
covered she said that she had to fight
them
to not lift him his toe but he's got
cracked ribs
um sorry i i've been
i've been working in the background and
i appreciate y'all
take uh taking up the slack when working
in the background trying to find out
about this uh
this um this beirut thing but thank you
um revolutionary revolutionary communist
party
has endorsed their presidential
candidate yes they have
i can take a guess who it is
joe biden and you know i had to do a
little
um i had to do a little background
history of this party
and found out that our that our partners
rit had done
or had uh uh found um
did this video about them back in 2016
when the revolutionary communist party
uh tried to infiltrate the republican
national convention
now if y'all don't know anything about
the republican um the
revolutionary communist party
and well as i just said they just put
their
they they just uh endorsed joe biden if
you don't know anything about this party
this video it's itself should let you
know and this by rt
uh should let you know exactly who these
communists are
uh
that ain't democracy in china that is
exploiting the chinese people in
cambodia who died
because of the carpet bombing of the u.s
to what's coming out in this republican
national convention
we're not looking back to history
because you go back into history every
empire
built itself up through oppression and
exploitation
america was never great
so these are the people that are backing
joe biden
i'm not surprised and did you hear what
do you hear what the leader said
the leader of the revolutionary common
communist party did you hear what he
said no great
he said biden is not better than trump
in any meaningful way
what i mean that's a quote that's
gaslighting right there that's just
that's that's getting people's heads
twisted up but it just
we said in that in that clip right there
we're not looking back on history
yeah i know you don't want to look back
on history don't look back on
how we started where we came from and
how far we've come
this this country was founded on
judeo-christian moral values
which if you follow those you live a
pretty healthy and happy life
you really do uh coupled with capitalism
because capitalism needs a moral compass
those two combined together and the
government to serve the people
has never been happened in all of human
history and and within just a couple
hundred years
we've become the greatest superpower
that
human beings have ever seen
in all of human history america has
become the greatest
country the most sought after everybody
wants to live here
our good friend trevor louden wrote the
book enemies within
talking about uh he's he's from new
zealand and he started following
communism because he wanted to see
you know where'd all this come from and
he documents
all the democrats and republicans bought
and paid for
by communist regimes and i asked him
about islam he said
islam is the exact same thing just a
different name it's all to enslave the
people
so now we've got the democrat party
coupled with islam
coupled with communism all one big thing
and joe biden got prashanko fired for
investigating his son
you know there you go there you go
that sums it up um the leader's name is
bob akavian
i guess yeah i skipped over that's why i
just said the leader
yo yosemite um
to be clear this means not a protest
vote for some candidate
who has no chance of winning but
actually voting for the democratic party
candidate
yeah um a candidate that's not even
gonna show up
for his i mean and look i'm not gonna
i'm not making a big deal about it
because president trump is not gonna
show up
for his either so uh but uh
you know trump said i ain't inviting the
media to my
yeah hell no they don't deserve it
just a quick flashback as i'm thinking
here uh
could you imagine if hillary clinton won
um yeah it's called hell just take that
in just for
just for a split second hillary won
it would have been eight years of her
yeah and then somebody else that she
tapped
we would never we would never be a
country ever again
and i'm not trying to say that to get
people triggered but
holy hell man donald trump beat
everybody
here's one here's one isis would still
be around
oh yeah we would have a ton of terrorist
attacks on this land
yeah isis would still be chopping
people's heads off and stuff you're not
seeing much of that anymore are you
well no because obama's gone no not at
all
those were obama's buddies
they were created under his lead yeah
the founding fathers of isis
barack obama hillary clinton and yours
and mine uh
truly uh john mccain you might as well
throw joe biden in there too
burn in hell cheeks um
and the stuff and the stuff happening
over in syria see
her policy was empathy
was it yes yeah it was empty it was
empathy
okay that was her policy and that's the
dems policy
i mean look at what's happening in
portland empathy you
i mean minnesota the mayor thought he
could go out and talk to the crowd and
then they
shamed him empathy does not equal peace
does not equal peace
he got hit with a can didn't he yeah
well i mean they
he he took a little skinny squishy
skinny jeans squishy shoe yourself and
just walked away
and like a dog with his
tail wagging between his legs walked
away
uh same thing happened up in portland
the mayor or yeah
the mayor went down there and got
shouted out of there
yeah he did you know
yeah everything doesn't work with these
people bro
i mean brian said it they empathy
is a a way of showing weakness with
these people
and you embolden the bully because they
are being bullies
shouting you down forcing you to do what
they want you to do
by hook or by crook by violence by
whatever means possible
they will force you to do what they want
that's called a bully
and appeasers like these weak democrats
appeasing to the bully
never works and and it's it's actually
y'all's fault
you have gas lit an entire generation
you've gas lit the whole damn generation
into thinking
what's right is wrong what's wrong is
right it's upside down
hey nice cup there man yeah nice cup
there leah
wayne yours is going to be there i have
your tracking number
it's almost there
the mailing got messed up just another
reason not to vote by mail
it is just another reason not to vote by
mail i mailed him out
he got his you didn't get yours because
mail just doesn't do that for those that
are
standing up for the united states postal
service
you better step back take a second look
the united states postal service if uh
it was an entity
amongst itself like a business like ups
fedex something like that would be
completely
bankrupt in a day the ups would be
bankrupt and the internet and technology
has made that even worse
so just saying i knew it i knew it
i knew it the cops are coming y'all
nice cupcakes are coming you guys can
have your morning coffee with us
afternoon coffee that's right or tea
because i drink tea
no not after 1776 1776.
we're like nancy pelosi vodka
she drank some breakfast oh no
but i'm praying um
yeah the devil not really praying to the
porcelain gods
like coffee or tea wayne and lee
um i've never had i i've never had i've
never tried coffee
i only drink tea did y'all hear that i
know people are like oh that's
unbelievable
nobody can do it no potato no mayonnaise
no
ketchup mustard miracle never had it
never tried it
my mother can attest to it never had any
of it that my wife
my wife and her family put on
corn mayonnaise oh oh no
and parmesan cheese hmm that makes me
want to gag
it's a southern california hispanic
thing it's a country thing
no no i can't do it that's a nasty
even if i see ketchup in the
refrigerator and somebody wants me to
grab it for them i'm i can't i don't
even want to touch it
that's how grossed out i get by it so
hey do you see that thing with sally
yates
i love it love it ladies and gentlemen
right now sally yates
is testifying and um
a lot of us have been kind of hard on um
lindsay
um well he's lighting the loafers
something going on there oh
now you got him doing it see that was
from back in the 80s i haven't done that
since i was since i was a kid
disney um
lindsay has decided that he's going to
be a little bulldog today
he is a bulldog yeah i'm like
look at look at him go i mean he
deserves a coffee cup
yeah he does he does he does he he's up
for reelection though
yeah nice cups guys i love them they
look great
well he he was so happy when she said it
too he sat back in his seat yeah he did
didn't you yeah
what happened yeah he's like yeah well
if y'all don't know what we're talking
about thank you very much uh you
mentioned
shock value that is shocking what the
russians did i agree we need to stop it
did you read the horowitz report
machetes
were you shocked by it i
certainly was shocked yes i think that
the conduct that was reflected there
so let's talk about that conduct right
quick we're talking about
using a document that came from a
russian sub-source
to get a warrant against an american
citizen
repeatedly that was full of garbage does
that bother you
well i'm not sure does it bother you
that the fisa court
rebuked the department of justice and
fbi regarding the quarter
carter page warrant application
senator i believe that the department of
justice and the fbi have a duty of
candor with the fisa court that do you
believe they fulfill that duty
no i do not believe that they did i
think that there were matter of fact
you signed that warrant application in
october and january is that correct
that's right knowing now knowing then
what you know now would you sign that
application
senator i would never sign any document
because that document was a fraud is
that a fair statement if you knew then
what you know now you wouldn't have
signed it
i wouldn't sign anything that i knew to
contain errors or remissions
did that contain errors in admissions
yeah
and i would never knowingly sign a
document i i didn't do that in the 27
years i believe you didn't know
i believe you didn't know that what you
signed was wrong the question is if you
had known you wouldn't assign it is that
correct
no if i had known that it contained
incorrect information i certainly
wouldn't have signed
thank you and do you agree with me it
did contain
incorrect information i i know that now
based on the horowitz
that's all i'm trying to say
that's all i'm trying to say i'm trying
to say boy
he got her twisted yeah all right guys
let's dial it back go ahead no no i i
i'm just saying these people get paid
the big bucks sally yates gets paid to
big bucks
and i just think it's a travesty every
time that they
cheat the american people uh do
something wrong to the american people
uh do something wrong in their job that
when they get caught before congress
and they get paid the big bucks they
don't know nothing right right
i didn't know nobody told me or all
right
and then they go off and spend time on
their yacht or respectively
on their summer home and stuff you know
i mean ron rosenstein is still out there
oh he's free yeah he's free as a jaybird
then nothing's ever going to happen to
that that that guy
which he should be in prison as well
right dialing it back
let's do just a little flashback there
sally yates uh look where you came from
uh the election was november 8th uh
hillary clinton was unconsolable
the world was shot the world was shocked
world leaders
were shot i wasn't i was republican i
wasn't us voters that voted for trump we
we took back our country uh by voting
donald trump in
and then all of a sudden they had to uh
call up the insurance policy
said december 29th uh
december 29 2016 barack hussein obama
expelled 35 russian diplomats claiming
that it was russian interference
and then we know that uh russian
diplomat kislyak
which was in regular talking with
general flynn because of flynn's
position
called flynn while i was on vacation uh
i believe
down in the dominican republic or
whatever
down there and said hey man what's going
on general flynn hanging out with family
on vacation probably having a drink or
two
by chilling out oh man i just heard what
obama did i know i don't know anyone
wait till i get back to dc and then a
couple days later almost a week later
january 5th 2017
barack hussein obama james comey
mccabe clapper brennan fbi
cia heads up all the the biggest heads
of the biggest heads
and we know this because susan rice
wrote an email to herself about this
and who else was there sally yates
you're sitting there at the table with
obama
and obama's looking at him and sure as
the day is long i'd bet my life that
this is what he said
or something similar to that you guys
i'm out of here in 15 days trump's in
in 15 days on the 20th inauguration day
you all are still here you all still
running it
you gots to overturn this thing you got
it we got to get him
expelled we've got to do something we've
got to
wreck it ruin it and wreck it there was
the beginning of the coup
that day january 5th 2017 at barack
hussein obama's office
with you sally yates who signed off on
the fake
fake news dawson i will tell you
i will tell you obama wanted to wreck
his presidency not because he wanted
hillary in
but because there's so so much stuff
behind the scenes that we don't know
what obama was trying to do
and how he was trying to destroy this
country
and that is why he won direct don't get
it confused it wasn't it wasn't about
hillary it was a about obama and all his
mess-ups
and everything that he did you know he
said he was scandal free no he wasn't
scandal free
he just hit it well he just hit it well
and that is exactly why he was trying to
get
trump out of the presidency because he
knew trump wasn't going to take anything
and he was going to throw it out there
and i hope
yeah hillary's email guys if we don't
want this we all hang
and and some and something that should
trouble all of us
is that sally yates went with what they
gave her
yeah or at least that's what she's
saying yeah they put it in front of me i
just signed oh sure i'll just sign it
away
there was most of and that should make
every american
uh um fearful about what could happen to
you
because she didn't as as
being in charge of her department or i
guess running she didn't do any in-depth
checking
she didn't she because listen when you
put your name on something
that makes you accountable i don't care
how much you say i don't know
you are supposed to be accountable right
but she's thinking it's dc
i'm not held accountable for anything
who cares right away
right let's just make a real real
distinction
if it was a document to come across her
desk that was
something to do with the ukraine or
something to do with something else
uh that you've never heard of before joe
schmoe out of
arkansas that connected to the clintons
so anyways i can understand
maybe pencil whipping that because they
told you that this is true
and it's just a civilian whatever this
was
donald j trump the running
against your party for president
of the united states of america james
comey
signed off on it uh mccabe signed off
yates signed off rosenstein signed they
all signed off
on probably the most important document
that could have ever come across their
desk that
this wasn't joe down the street this is
a presidential election that you
all interfered with well they were
desperate to get them out of there
because of how many secrets and how many
scandals they had
that wasn't my favorite part of the
lindsey graham i got another one
yeah hold on now let's talk about a
january 5th meeting
um was the vice president there
yes he was okay did he mention the logan
act
you know i don't remember the vice
president saying much of anything
miss me so you don't remember him
mentioning the logan act
no i don't did anybody mention the logan
act
i have a vague memory uh director comey
mentioning the logan act
okay what was he mentioning about in
what context
well that's i'm not sure if he mentioned
that
in the oval office meeting or in the
meeting
what do you think about that mr chairman
let her answer the question
just because it's a woman testifying
doesn't mean she has to be cut off yeah
thanks a lot
senator lee i really appreciate that
you're very constructive
so here's my question was the logan act
mentioned in the meeting i don't
i recall director comey mentioning it at
some point
but i'm not sure about senator graham
and i want to be
fair that's fair you don't know if it's
mentioned in the meeting or not
do you believe that i do work with
director clement mentioned
at some point i'm not sure why i got you
okay
here's the question did uh general
kislek's
behavior amount to violation of the
logan act in your opinion
it certainly could have been a technical
violation but that was not the focus
of the fbi or us that we were really
focused on a counterintelligence
investment well
do you realize on january the 4th
the fbi recommended to drop general
flynn from crossfire hurricane
i understand well i know that now i
didn't know that at the time
but here's my point on january the 4th
the fbi said there's no reason to keep
looking at general flynn
on january the 5th you have a meeting
with the fbi director
where you believe he mentions the logan
act in regard to general flynn
is that correct what i understand
senator graham is that and i didn't know
at the time because i wasn't privy to
the fbi's
um internal documentation of the
counterintelligence investigation
did you even know what was going on
not specifically with respect to general
flynn no no i mean
you did not know the fbi had a
counterintelligence investigation of
general flynn
no i did not
let let her talk because she's a woman
let her talk because she's a woman how
about billboard they wouldn't let him
talk
straight right please she was what she
was thinking
right she was the attorney general she
was bill barr's position
they had a meeting the day after the fbi
was going to drop it
comey comey said logan act or maybe i
don't remember
maybe it was but sure it was no i don't
know anything about crossfire hurricane
not her
i'm reclaiming my time i'm reclaiming my
time i'm reclaiming
you know senator leahy you suck in the
batman movies and you suck as a u.s
senator right now you suck
you stop suck
i like yeah did you did you um
did you see how um linda's like yeah uh
yeah yeah
yeah thanks for the contract
i loved it i loved it
these folks are the elected officials
and this
is why the world is laughing
that wasn't my favorite part of the
hearing though i had another favorite
part
oh i don't have that one
that's my favorite part he says steli
so you agree that comey went rogue and
she says
yes i agree and he just sits back in his
chair and he was like
finally i was celebrating
so sally is uh throwing
comey clearly throwing oh we've got
proof that comey lied
to congress and we also know that comey
illegally leaked documents to the
professor because he told us
the notes that were classified with
trump meeting
gave to the professor to then leak to
the media
to get a special counsel triggered so
predict
prediction it's headline news that sally
yates agrees
that uh comey went rogue during flynn
probe okay that's the headline
guarantee you comey's gonna tweet out
like a picture of trees and a rock
and just say something like real real
like
and in the trees there's a breeze and we
can feel it coming
you know how he is he he just randomly
tweets these weird pictures
so i've got a feeling he's going to do
that today just one random picture
that's his way of enjoying his freedom
for now yeah yeah well i mean and he's
nervous he
you know what he he probably spends half
the day in the bathroom because he's
nervous
he's reading the paper
not another one is his wife honey
not another one
so uh the beautiful miss lea bella
wanted to hear her favorite her favorite
sally yates response so
through the magic beauty of disney and
of the phone call
this was a counter intelligence
investigation of the trump campaign's
potential
um uh relationship with the russians
that makes no sense on january the
fourth they recommend to drop
flynn they mentioned the logan act and
you advised against prosecuting
the logan act is that true we never made
an official decision about whether we
were going to do it but i think it was
unlikely certainly unlikely that we
would receive a prosecution
and that was not our primary concern yes
it was a counter intelligence okay
here's what i want to understand
it's a counterintelligence investigation
that led to the interview
you didn't authorize the interview as a
matter of fact you wanted to go to the
white house and tell them
about the problem didn't you that's
right i did i thought that that was the
more immediate
issue and when you when you heard about
the interview you got upset
didn't you i was upset that director
comey didn't coordinate that with us and
acted unilaterally yes i was
okay did comey go rogue
then you could use that term yes
finally i loved it he took a deep breath
and he was like
finally great
uh just the juxtaposition literally i am
putting that on my christmas cards
i'm gonna like people are gonna open up
and see that visually and i'm just gonna
say merry christmas
what she's talking about doing dial it
all the way back to john mccain
john mccain's head of his campaign uh
was introduced to paul manafort
was going to bring him on board the fbi
approached
john mccain and his uh uh this guy that
was running his uh campaign
approached him and said you guys need to
back off manafort's got ties to russian
oligarchs
what she's talking about doing you know
we probably
should tell trump that you know what's
going on
that's what they should have done but
they they couldn't do that because this
was
a true coup d'etat so this is a beaut
this is going to be a beautiful domino
effect
because what she just said there she
thinks what she said there was just
a sentence but that's going to be huge
because they can take that
and run with it and if they get comey
i'll tell you what he
he's such a little snake such a little
pee brain that he's going to throw
everybody else under which is great
which is great because he has no
backbone and i'm telling you
they could possibly get obama on
something because comey's gonna throw
everybody under the bus
because he's just he'll be scared to
death imagine what happens when trump
trump wins re-election
i i can't i don't want to i mean he's
going to be
well i mean are you talking about good
or bad because
everything every everything it is going
to be
you want to talk about arm again yeah
i'm not trying to get everybody all up
no no no no
you're right you're right you're totally
right i'm just saying holy hell
nancy bar the doors yeah
no you're right you're right because um
and
this is where um uh
um um or slash republicans
this is where y'all have to really um
grow up uh because
many people many republicans and
conservatives like well you know look i
gotta work
i gotta take care of family i gotta do
this and that let me tell you something
president trump get reelected these
these these democrats are gonna go
nuts they're gonna go crazy no i'm sorry
they're already going nuts and crazy
they're gonna times that by
a hundred okay they're gonna times that
by a hundred
and they and and they're gonna go but if
they see y'all
standing your ground if they if they see
us standing on the ground and they see
us
not backing down that's the way that you
beat a bullet
you don't back down you stay calm right
yeah stay calm stay solid
and unwavering that's how you beat a
bully down
right and i think when trump gets
re-elected
and he he's he's going to come back
times a million on these people because
he doesn't have anything to lose
so i'm telling you the democrats might
want to rethink their plan of going
ballistic
because he's just going to be trump
times 10. something else on the back end
i know somebody said something uh
anybody uh shocked about the news that
clinton and epstein connection i'm
looking at that and there was a guy that
i follow on twitter i don't have his
name but i i reposted it so follow me on
twitter you'll see what i posted
uh the names of the politicians
there must have been 20 or 30 different
names of
current politicians everywhere from
mayor to senators to congress people
that are currently in prison
pedophilia child trafficking sex
trafficking
republicans democrats mayors
all across this country that are being
arrested and imprisoned
for all these things that nobody's
talking about
this is why they hate trump this is why
they hate trump
he's not part of their cabal
right and uh we were talking about this
yesterday
uh all the presidents including barack
obama whether you want to believe it or
not all the presidents
except for president trump all the
presidents are
um uh i'm connected in a way
in a way uh and what i mean by that
bloodline all the presidents except for
president trump barack obama too his
mama
his mama and his grandparents
yeah so bushes yeah so so
the thing here is that president trump
was is
outside of that and when y'all
us we decided to put
him in instead of their little
uh monarchy or whatever you want to call
it
they got bit they got mad they got
pissed off that's why they want to do
the mail-in voting
that's why the only way they can win is
if they cheat
that's the only way and and this is the
way everybody should be looking at the
mail in voting
the democrats are pushing this
remember they lost in 2016. they're
pushing this to
to be mandatory because
in their world in their utopian fantasy
they believe
nobody in the united states of america
is going to
cheat through mailing voting
and and and and um get rid of president
trump
they're the biggest cheaters yeah a
friend of mine told me that they
received eight mail-in
uh ballot votings and there's only four
people at the house
yeah it's just it's no good that's what
i'm talking about
no good some of these states have gone
to 20 percent of bad mail-in voting
uh um uh was um
what's it called when something
disqualified
uh oh yeah because of something being
wrong 10 to 20
can you imagine if that was on a
national scale 10 to 20 percent
you're talking about 14 to 28 million
people
who whose um votes wouldn't be counted
and trump was right trump's right when
he said it could take months or years
to try to figure out who won and then
what and then what i mean
trump well when we saw it he didn't
almost lose but
but there's three million votes that we
now know
illegals voted we know now fraudulent
votes and 3 million that was 2016.
they want to crush this uh more than
ever before
and now we've got the trump
administration suing the state of nevada
for this it is truly vote harvesting
that's what it is that's all it is yeah
and then you and then you talk about the
ballot harvesting on top of the mail-in
voting
and that doesn't have anything to do
with absentee we're not talking about
that no
absentee is totally different right
and the thing is the democrats are
scared that's why they're trying to push
this kind of voting because they know
they're going to lose
you know gun sales were up the highest
that they have been in july
i'm sorry but anybody buying a gun is
not vote in joe biden i can promise you
that
also first-time republican voters
registering is up
it is at record breaking so that tells
you right there
how huge this is the democrats know that
right
right and we were talking i don't know
if we brought this up on
the show yesterday but i know in our
little private chat we were talking
about camilla harris and and folks if he
picks camilla harris
there's just no way there's too much
dirt too much baggage on camila harris
there's just no way he can pick her
the other woman that he is looking at
picking i forget her name uh
older black woman uh she's peggy bass
yeah best card carrying communist
marxist tied with islam
what so who's it gonna be susan rice or
michelle obama
big mike it could be big mike hey
crazier things have happened in 2020
we didn't think we'd be in a pandemic
here we are and they called
and and if y'all don't know the
craziness of joe biden's
choices here they are she put over 1500
people in jail for marijuana violations
and then laughed about it when she was
asked if she ever smoked marijuana
i didn't i did it you support
the medicare for all bill i believe it
will totally eliminate private insurance
let's eliminate all of that let's move
on it began
spontaneously in benghazi as
a reaction to what had transpired some
hours earlier
in cairo sparked by this uh hateful
video
on the story of benghazi do you have any
regrets
david no that's why the words are
excited
of your founder l ron hubbard in the
creed of the church of scientology
the passing of the commandante and jefe
is a great
loss to the people of cuba i absolutely
would have not put that statement out
my apology is an apology for not having
been
more sensitive about tribal citizenship
hold on a sec i'm gonna get me um
a beer
it's hilarious you know
as funny as this is and as laughable as
this is
how do you take it serious yeah
can you imagine if joe biden was running
republican and the democrats can you
imagine how much they'd eat him alive
and how much they'd pick on him if he
was running as a republican
think about that think about all the
attacks they would say about him
you ain't black his 40 years of racism
the way you can't talk
think of i mean what they're ignoring
now are you just calling
another black guy a junkie yeah oh he's
so racist
it's terrible real quick before we go la
los angeles votes to advance bill to
relocate 88
no 888 million dollars from law
enforcement
to social programs
yeah that'll turn out good oprah winfrey
is blocking everybody on twitter
from commenting on her white shame
special that's getting ready to come up
oh and we do have a tweet from president
trump
sally hates has zero credibility she was
part of the greatest political crime of
the century
and obama by knew everything sally yates
leaked
the general flynn conversation question
mark
ask her under oath republicans
should start playing the democrats game
we've been saying that forever
by the way if you guys don't forget
donald trump and his travel ban from
people from countries
that couldn't prove who those people
were you could prove
any kind of documentation where they
were coming from where they were that
was the travel ban
sally yates told donald trump stick it
up yours and donald trump had fire
yeah for for those that are patreon
members thank you so much for
being patreon members for trying to get
to 500
uh and right now we are at 108
now we're at 108 i'm i think uh the ones
in red
are from july to august
thank you so much thank you the ones
that have
stars are two years or more
so we want to give them thanks for for
being with us for over two years uh
and uh for those that uh
are joining or would like to join you
can go to patreon.com for slash wd show
um and hopefully real soon
we'll be able to add this cup to
this uh this cup to uh one into the
tears
yeah and it's less than i figured out
it's less than 17 cents a day
if you do you know the five dollar one
less than 17.
that's nothing yeah and
and we're trying to work it out with the
with the people that
will be able to send you one of these so
we're working on it
big paul said why is my wife on the list
she got she got common sense big paul
i love you bro do you do i have anything
uh
well i can tell you that all the time
national day of resistance for the
teachers
and they said they're not going back to
school unless it's police free schools
they want their rent and mortgage
cancelled and they also want
billionaires and wall street to pay for
the re-opening of schools
so they don't want any police in school
so you know when there's police
shootings they just want to
not have not police shootings but
whenever they're school shootings they
don't want the police there now
they just want to take care of it
themselves unbelievable and donald trump
is the result of decades
of you politicians on both sides lying
to us
cheating us fake news giving us the bush
dynasty given us the uh uh
obama dynasty jamming john mccain down
our throats like that's who we were
supposed to vote for
and then given us giving us mittens
mitt romney this was fallout this is
last back
for what y'all have been doing to us
americans
right for decades um
for those that are on twitter you're
probably gonna get a notification
about android so
uh it looks like uh there's some leakage
of uh
data or something going through so those
that have android
phones so uh make sure that you check
that out
again if you want to check out the wayne
dupree show along with leah
and brian you can always download our
new
app on android okay
uh you can watch the shows and i think
you can do it live
i i think you can watch us live when we
go
live um if anybody in the chat room has
android and they're watching on their
phones
through android let us know but it's
free
you don't have to pay anything i see
some people in the chat room yesterday
we did
we let the chat room vote on we should
do a florida woman story or florida man
story
and now i see people todd wagner's like
florida woman there's people in there
asking for a florida woman's story i
found one
uh florida woman kicked off american
airlines flight for wearing an offensive
mask
uh she had f the police on her mask well
f12 which means
the police she was kicked off so there's
your florida story
um soily said this is the first time
they've been uh they've seen the show
a great show guys excellent show hey
thanks thanks for being
thank you thank you crush to follow so
um
we will be back tomorrow at uh 12
noon so make sure that you are there
have your face in the place and before
we go
we want to say thank you once again for
being part of
what we do and we look forward to seeing
you
again tomorrow 12 to 1 p.m eastern
standard time
remember support the show join us on
patreon.comwd show
and remember like like we always say
don't think somebody else is going to do
it and you don't do it
because then nobody might be doing it
okay that's that's something that we all
should do
let me leave you with a message from
president trump
y'all have a great evening the more that
a broken system
tells you that you're wrong the more
certain you should be
that you must keep pushing ahead
because it's the outsiders who change
the world
and make a real and lasting difference
nothing worth doing ever
came easy treat the word impossible
as nothing more than motivation
the future belongs to the people who
follow their heart no matter what
the critics say we must always remember
that we share one home and one
glorious destiny we all believe
the same red blood of patriots
we all salute the same great american
flag
our best days are yet
to come
you